foreign
is with us Elizabeth is in Pensacola
Florida Merry Christmas Elizabeth
Merry Christmas Dave thank you and John
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas how can
we help
I um
for coming up on
here with a man
United father to his two girls and I
also have a daughter and we started off
so wide open and hopeful and we were
discussing the possibility and dream of
marriage and blending our families and
how that could work but little by little
issues regarding lots of things
including boundaries with the kids have
seen to put a huge damper on our
relationship and due to his behavior
moods my daughters pretty much lost all
respect for him and despises him now and
at this point our relationship is
unrecognizable from a year ago since
I've retreated to where I felt I
wouldn't step on any toes out of
difference and respect
but I'm also struggling with a feeling I
should walk away but also not wanting to
abandon what we've tried to build
how old is your daughter
13 and a half
they're perfectly capable of causing
entire countries to cave in
but they also 13 year olds
um I was just talking about this on my
show earlier today
their their sonar
for not safe is often much more in tune
than ours are as adults because like you
just mentioned you've got a fantasy
you can't you come from heartbreak you
want to the idea of a family and you
meet this guy and right out of the gate
it's going to be awesome and all of a
sudden the the the picture you all paint
together looks incredible
and then reality starts to open up over
the last year and you have enough
strength and fortitude and grit
determination I'm gonna marry this guy I
don't care if he's the worst guy I I
want that picture and your 13 year old
saying I'm not gonna be around him
because she's still in touch with she
hasn't lost that sense of herself yet
here's my my hard hard question for you
it sounds like you've already broken up
with him you haven't broken up the
fantasy
yeah because I just like and and John on
your recommendation I bought that book
love uh facing love addiction uh by Tia
Melody and I I'm trying to look at
myself and say
is this just you know but I I do I love
him and care about him so much and it
it's just hard to let go because
both of those things can be true at the
same time
you can love somebody deeply and they're
not the right person to connect to hit
your wagon to for the rest of your life
you can break up with somebody and be
devastated and still be the right thing
to do
those things aren't mutually exclusive
and I'm not telling you to dump him I
would never tell somebody to do that
unless there's abuse or something so I'm
not telling you got to leave them but
I'm just holding up a mirror to what you
just told me and Dave is you're done
with this relationship you're not done
with the idea of what could have been
which bucket
um
your 13 year old doesn't want anything
to do with him she's lost all respect
for him is it because he called her out
on her stuff and no one has lately and
she's a little 13 year old butt or is it
because
um she's seeing stuff that you know is
right
you know trying to tell her hey why does
she not respect him exactly
um he gets kind of Moody and she thinks
that he's not acting like mature and I
agree those times where he gets like
triggered by things and he'll kind of
act moody or her or something and it's
like I think she's looking just like I
am for that leader and I've Got The
Compassion because you're like oh I'll
work with him I'll work with and she's
just like nah you know she's when you
say moody is it that Sunday afternoon
dad just that there's a bear over there
on the couch watching football you
better not talk to him or touch him or
is it is he ugly is he ugly things he
just ignore people what do you mean be
specific about the behaviors
um so like uh for instance sometimes
um even specifically towards her like he
kind of didn't give a benefit of the
doubt for something let's say and you
know and he kind of acted like she
wasn't
um acting right when she was just being
a normal kid or or also you know just
the way that she's seen him interact
with because he's got a a thought or two
that's her age and so you know I'm sure
they chat you know and so just seeing
how sometimes he reacts to her and then
the daughter's reaction to that there's
like I didn't even go into some things
that she's seen that I also wasn't okay
with over at his place where just
there's some family Dynamics there that
I'm not like
both you and him have been around the
block meaning y'all have been through
heartbreak y'all have had you've had
other marriages before you've had other
relationships
is there an opportunity for y'all to sit
down with adult like like in a very
adult conversation almost like a like an
accounting review
um an audit and just say hey this last
year has been tough
Let's either let's agree that we're
gonna we're gonna start acting different
we want this thing to work and we're
going to both begin to or continue to
invest in this thing or let's
we're going to be heartbroken and it's
going to be hard but let's choose to
move on could you do that could you have
that conversation and for the and say
some of your needs out loud
yeah and I've been trying to and it
seems like he kind of like doesn't
um I don't know if he's really very
available to give me what I need which
also and I even used some words I heard
on your show like I'm worth you know
being loved from who I am or like I'm
worth this I have a lot to offer and
like I'm you know and he's kind of like
I don't know he just I don't I don't
think he actually appreciates my my
worth and I'm trying to I don't know I
think maybe that's also part of it too
you're done yeah I mean that's what
you're telling us you just you just
outlined somebody that's done
and I wanted and Dave I like want
someone to treat me like how you treat
Sharon I want John I want someone to
treat me like how you treat you like I
want that and I just your daughter
doesn't because I would be dismissal
dismissive of her if she was if your
household is kids Centric and your kid
thinks she's the old be-all and she's
13. I would be dismissive of her so you
really wouldn't want me
not pedestal and I'm not like some Diva
no not you her
you get to be on the pedestal that's
your job the 13 year old doesn't
right right and that's what I feel like
I feel like and I literally put my hand
down on the ground I was like I feel
like I'm down here and like let's say
his you know mom and his sister and your
mom or sister are there
you should have left with my you should
have led with Mom LED with Mama yeah
hey here's what here's what you're what
I think we're gonna reindeer your uh
your body's gearing up for another
breakup and it remembers the last one
and it was painful and awful so get some
people in your life because you're about
to enter into a hard season yeah and uh
get some hot tea and two good friends
we'll we'll walk alongside you this
one's done be tough